[Music]
the question for today is if you had to
wear a warning sign what would it say
the caution fragile warning he's a he's
very shy
[Music]
I'd say treat me like you should treat
your mother cover your kids ears warning
hands are registered lethal weapons
black belt in judo so if I get arrested
then I'll probably get charged with
something my warning sign was a warning
might be [ __ ] warning might pinch you
warning might bite you warning my kids
may hurt you
mostly harmless supergun ho Tasha and
work-in-progress
caution won't put up with [ __ ] don't
leave unattended let's say leave me
alone I wouldn't have a warning sign I
would just just just be nice
[Music]
warning I'm awesome
[Music]
warning
objects are cooler than they appear
watch out I'm a blonde yeah watch out
I'm a blonde something like that
I don't warning sign' I'd probably say
Tosh and I bite now probably something
about climate change I'm an
environmental science major so just
letting people know that it's real and
it's happening and there's probably
gonna die if we keep consuming at the
rate that we are so probably like
warning the earth will die a warning be
good to me
[Music]
watch out I'm mr. malice
battle off until I get my coffee and
then we can all be friends
it would warn people that the world
isn't as bad as we think it is warning
excessive nagging about household chores
something like that be careful who
you're asking
it would say warning be prepared cuz
dreams do come true it adjusts a warning
only for the simple fact is I don't want
to give away anything it's just warning
so beware everything warning I break for
chocolate I guess it would say our
actions matter my warning sound with
alert people stop look and listen
[Music]
warning mom brain I guess I would had
seemed a little socially awkward and a
little nervous and shy at first I'm a
little shy watch out
I would say we kind of one another
otherwise the squirrels gonna come to an
end danger danger was supposed to
explode happy things
guys my name is Raya and I'm the owner
of the channel I'm also the person
behind the camera and I thought I'd take
a minute to thank all the subscribers I
gained so far and maybe ask the new
years to hit the subscribe button if you
liked this episode or if you're a fan of
my channel in general a lot thank you
[Music]
[Music]